[Musik]
dritter monat krieg in der ukraine und
vor allem im osten des landes toben die
kämpfe weiter russland ist dort sehr
bemüht die ukrainische truppen dort
teilweise einzukesseln und versucht
weiter vorzudringen und benutzt dafür
alle möglichen waren wir sehen uns
einmal kurz die lage an im osten der
ukraine wo weiter stark gekämpft und vor
allem zeigen dass mal ein vor allem hier
in diesem gebiet rund um tv donetzk also
die letzten kleinen anteile in lugansk
in dieser region lohans hier die sollen
erobert werden da versucht russland um
jeden preis wir sehen noch mal diese
kleine linie um jeden preis diese
letzten gebiete zu erobern das sozusagen
der allererste ziel da lohans zu erobern
und danach den eroberern und danach
weiter vorzudringen vorzurücken in
richtung westen wie macht russland das
ja wir haben tatsächlich neue aufnahmen
hier von der ja es hört sich so rosig an
von der tulpe das ist die zwei
s40 pan oder auf deutsch tulpe das ist
der schwerste moerser der welt der hier
eingesetzt wird von russland und man
sieht hier auch russische propagandisten
also vom staatsfernsehen die davor
stehen und sehr stolz das ganze erklären
was hier passiert 24 zentimeter breit
also 240 mm sind diese moerser die ihr
abgefeuert werden ungefähr zehn bis
zwanzig kilometer und das gefährliche
ist dass dieser mörder auch atomraketen
also atom moerser 10 km weit abfeuern
kann also ein extrem schwieriges zeichen
und ein wichtiges zeichen für russland
wir haben jetzt atomwaffenfähige ja
moerser schwere moerser 28 tonnen wiegt
der hier in der ukraine und schießen
damit in europäischen interessanterweise
haben offenbar ukrainische soldaten hier
mit gesehen was die russische propaganda
sich angeguckt hat haben sich angesehen
wo steht dieser mörderischen und haben
ihnen dann angegriffen hier sehen wir
wieder moerser sich in einem hangar
versteckt und wir sehen darauf immer
wieder anschläge der ukraine die also
immer diesen hangar beschießen und
darauf warten dass der moerser dann weg
fährt hier sehen wir es der moerser hat
sich heraus bewegt da ist ja da sehen
wir noch mal 24 kumpan wie gesagt der
schwersten moerser der welt er bewegt
sich wird aber beobachtet von der
ukrainischen drohne die dann wiederum
die daten wie immer an die art wie
weitergibt jetzt versteckt er sich hier
und wir sehen das in dieser alten fabrik
dort dieser moerser angegriffen wird und
dann hier sehen ganz gut hier sehen wir
mal diesen moerser von eben mit diesen
ewig langen rohr sozusagen dieses
moerser wo die abgeschossen werden um
ihm zehn bis zwanzig kilometer weit zu
fliegen die moerser dann auch brennt das
heißt dieser russische propaganda aktion
ging nach hinten los wir sehen jetzt
hier wie die munition explodiert um
wieder gesamte moerser sozusagen dann
geschichte ist die russen haben was
gefilmt haben es im staatsfernsehen
zeigt kann es veröffentlicht ein tag
später haben die ukrainer ganz offenbar
diese aufnahmen gesehen haben gesehen wo
ist das um die fabrik identifiziert und
haben dann in europäischen angegriffen
aber nicht nur in regional sondern auch
in anderen teilen des landes verstecken
sich russischer einheiten immer wieder
in kritischer infrastruktur hier sehen
wir eine ölgewinnung anlage in sabrina
sabrina eine region weiter im westen die
stadt polo etwa 20.000 einwohner und wir
sehen wie sich überall hier russische
einheiten verstecken eben genau da wo
sie wissen wenn wir angegriffen werden
hat die ukraine ein großes risiko ja ihr
eigenes öl zu zerstören ihre anlagen zu
zerstören ihre industrie zu zerstören
die kritische infrastruktur für die
gesamte stadt zu verstören und trotzdem
versuchen die ukraine hiermit so präzise
wie möglich mit ihrer artillerie
anzugreifen und wir sehen dass sie
tatsächlich ist schaffen zwischen diesen
öltanks die wir beispielsweise sehen ist
kann es mal ein paar einkreisen hier
sehen wir also die öltanks
beispielsweise hier sehen wir
verschiedene züge die auch teilweise
folgen sind mit öl und wir sehen hier
ist der ukrainische einschlag das heißt
der einschlag ist direkt daneben und
trifft dann einen versorgungs lkw der
russischen armee wir ziehen uns das
gleich noch mal an hier sind die überall
muss und dass man zu verzeichnen überall
russische militär fahrzeuge die sich
verstecken die also quasi zwischen den
anlagen stehen direkt neben fließen die
rohre wo das öl durch fließt und sie
versuchen so nah wie möglich dran zu
sein um sich hier zu sichern benutzen
also ukrainische infrastruktur kritische
infrastruktur als schutz um nicht von
der ukrainischen armee angegriffen zu
werden sie ist desto trotz an einem fall
schafft ist denn nur keine hier sehen
wir ein versorgungs lkw mit benzin
beladen dieser lkw wird jetzt gleich
getroffen da oben ist es geht es jetzt
in dem moment explodiert und in
schwarzem rauch dem wir jetzt sehen der
kommt nicht von der fabrik sondern der
kommt von diesem lkw mit dem benzin der
hier getroffen wurde hier sehen wir also
wieder das ist für die ukraine
glücklicherweise kein keine eigene
infrastruktur die brennt sondern
ausschließlich dieser lkw eben wieder
dieses zusammenspiel von präzisions
drohne auf der einen seite und genaue
arterie auf der anderen seite die hier
für die ukraine eine katastrophe
verhindern kann für die russen hier zum
verhängnis wird als letztes wollen wir
uns ansehen wiederum schwere waffen die
angekommen sind schwere waffen aus
europa aus der europäischen union die
extrem wichtig sind für die ukraine und
auf die sie weiterhin aus deutschland
wartet weiterhin haben wir trotz des
versprechens von kanzler scholz und
trotz des votums des deutschen
bundestages keine schweren deutschen
waffen in der ukraine andere länder
nämlich zum beispiel tschechien sind
hier wesentlich stärker hier sehen wir
ganz neu neueste aufnahmen von einem
sogenannten rem 70 das ist ein mehrfach
raketenwerfer aus tschechien auch der
ist zugegebenermaßen aus sowjetzeiten
aber tschechien liefert so was zumindest
und das ja dieser dieser werfer hat vor
nachteile vorteil ist dass er nicht nur
diese 40 raketen dort abholen kann
sondern das nochmal zurück sondern
direkt in dem fahrzeug versteckt so
zusage nicht versteckt sondern auch
gelagert weitere 40 raketen sind er also
eine sehr gute möglichkeit hat hier zu
feuern und eben zweimal nacheinander 40
raketen abzufeuern der nachteil ist dass
dieses fahrzeug noch relativ einfach ist
den grad raketenwerfer der russen so
etwa entspricht das ist aus den 80ern
und es ist auch relativ ungezielt das
ganze das heißt es lohnt sich nur auf
größere formationen des feindes ihr zu
schießen am ende gucken jetzt noch mal
an wie das extra aufgebaut ist hier
sehen wir es nämlich und sich gerade
erklärt habe einmal haben wir hinten
sozusagen die 40 raketen abgeschossen
werden und dann haben wir
direkt daneben gelagert hier nochmal
weitere 40 raketen die sozusagen schnell
ausgetauscht werden können um dann
weitere zu feuern dass also eine von
vielen schweren waffen die tschechien
geliefert hat die eben in der u-bahn zum
einsatz kommen auf die deutschen
schweren waffen die die ukraine
unbedingt braucht um im osten des landes
die russische offensive zurückzudrehen
wartet das land weiterhin
[Musik]